mama et daniel du gué résidents de
quatre bateaux propriétaire de ma maison
ici depuis 1991
je me suis ici parce que je suis né à
quatre bateaux juste un cerveau petit
coin de paradis
j'ai toujours vécu ici
avec les marées qui de plus en plus
hautes avec la fonte des glaciers
ça crée beaucoup de nos audiences de
propriété sans menacer de niveau 2 sont
menacés est en fait on a plus en plus
fréquentes
de plus en plus fort mais eva contre 800
km en voyez pas souvent ce qu'on pouvait
arriver une fois toutes les deux roues
avant
mais là ça arrivait souvent de trois
fois dans la même semaine
le 30 décembre 2016 j'ai perdu 17 pieds
de terrain juste d'un coup depuis 1991
je porte du 75 pieds de terrain en
vivent extrêmement stressé le sang puis
dessus puis nos terrains nos maisons cap
de la valeur nos puis nous pureté jeunes
notre eau potable est menacée mon club
tgv seulement avant que du mordu quatre
classes et de la protection à nos frais
moi j'ai pas les moyens de faire à la
vitesse que l'érosion ce fait
se séparer et et je pense que cette
question de questions des 5 à 6 ans
peut-être en vapeur d'eau maison ici
quand je regarde de faire un titre que
je me sens bien c'est
ça fait partie de moi j'imagine pas
vivre ailleurs
[Musique]